welcome to sneak ville
that was plastic and fake and they liked
it that way no nature no flowers no one
seemed to mind but a secret was waiting
for someone to find I said do you want
to see something cool whoa what are
those fries they used to grow all around
here what I want more than anything is
to see a real living tree but the
creators of Despicable Me
no one ever leaves top see what he's up
to comes the world of dr. Seuss as
you've never seen it before okay
so you want to know what happened to the
trees but I didn't think anyone still
cared well that's me the guy who still
cares it all started a long time ago
when I accidentally summon a mystical
creature as old as time itself The Lorax
Hey did you chop down this tree I think
he did it
hmm you need to change the way things
are I won't let you down
you got a beautiful town here dad if I
can't think of any reason you'd ever
want to go outside of town again
unless someone like you cares a whole
awful lot nothing is going to get better
it's not
I think the Lorax meant for you to have
this
the last feed it's not about what it is
it's about what it can become
I just kiss you right now
we don't have time dad I don't know we
have a little time dr. Seuss's home or
acts invited the giant furry peanuts
I'll go right up here no whoa you
wouldn't hit a woman that's a woman